les suites du voyage jacques chirac en
chine le président français signé
aujourd'hui avec son homologue chinois
une déclaration sur les droits de
l'homme les droits de l'homme au centre
de toutes les discussions de cette
deuxième journée
hervé de charette a demandé au ministre
des affaires étrangères chinois la
libération de dix sept dissidents
notamment celle d'un des leaders de la
contestation de la place tiananmen
laurent hakim il y avait bien deux
approches des relations franco-chinoises
ce vendredi à pékin sous les feux de la
rampe une déclaration politique plein
d'espoir et en coulisses les questions
qui dérangent
pour la diplomatie et les caméras on
avait réservé la signature par jacques
chirac et géant des mines d'une
déclaration conjointe pour un
partenariat global
le texte le plus important qui a été
signée par la france et la chine depuis
1964 selon le président français
soixante quatre dates de la
reconnaissance de la chine communiste
par de gaulle
cette déclaration conjointe implique la
reconnaissance par pékin de
l'universalité des droits de l'homme
alors en coulisses cette fois le terrain
devenait propice à l'évocation de 17
détenus chinois parmi lesquels deux
figures du printemps de pékin
hervé de charette a remis cette liste de
17 non aux ministres des affaires
étrangères chinois réclamant leur
libération
il faut dire que la france avait ces
derniers temps mauvaise presse sur la
question des droits de l'homme en chine
et notamment auprès des européens
après le refus par paris de signer la
résolution condamnant la chine devant la
commission des droits de l'homme de
l'onu prend france lionel jospin s'était
même interrogé sur l'audace et le
courage corée ou non jacques chirac sur
la question des droits de l'homme